vítej zpět u kurzu Pochopení kvantových informací a výpočtů, jmenuji se John Watrous a jsem technický ředitel pro vzdělávání
v IBM Quantum. Toto je devátá lekce série a první lekce třetí části, která se věnuje obecné
formulaci kvantových informací. Dosud jsme používali zjednodušenou formulaci
kvantových informací, kde jsou kvantové stavy reprezentovány komplexními vektory s euklidovskou normou rovnou
jedné. Naproti tomu v obecné formulaci kvantových informací jsou kvantové stavy reprezentovány
maticemi určitého typu, známými jako matice hustoty. Tato první lekce části se zaměřuje konkrétně na matice hustoty
a v průběhu lekce si řekneme, co jsou a jak fungují. Matice hustoty jsou extrémně
užitečné a nabízejí různé výhody, které probereme. Umožňují nám reprezentovat
širší třídu stavů než kvantové stavové vektory, včetně stavů systémů ovlivněných šumem a také náhodných
výběrů kvantových stavů. Podíváme se také na Blochovu sféru, která nám poskytuje velmi pěkný
a jednoduchý geometrický způsob, jak přemýšlet o stavech qubitů, a uvidíme, jak se pojí s maticemi hustoty
pozoruhodným způsobem prostřednictvím Pauliho matic. Nakonec probereme matice hustoty v kontextu více
systémů a zejména uvidíme, jak nám umožňují popisovat kvantové stavy systémů nahlížených izolovaně, i když
jsou korelovány s jinými systémy, a to včetně možnosti, že jsou s jinými systémy provázány. To je důležitá schopnost
a ve zjednodušené formulaci kvantových informací ji nelze snadno realizovat. Zde je přehled
lekce: začneme základy matic hustoty, včetně relevantních definic a příkladů, a probereme,
jak se pojí s kvantovými stavovými vektory. Poté si povíme o konvexních kombinacích matic hustoty, neboli
jinými slovy, co se stane, když budeme brát vážené průměry matic hustoty. Začneme konkrétním
příkladem tzv. úplně smíšeného stavu. Uvidíme, jak lze klasické pravděpodobnostní stavy chápat jako
speciální případy matic hustoty, a probereme, jak do toho vstupuje spektrální věta z lineární algebry
v tomto kontextu. Třetí část lekce se věnuje Blochově sféře, která poskytuje geometrický způsob nahlížení na stavy
jednotlivých qubitů, jak jsem zmínil na začátku lekce. Ve čtvrté části lekce si povíme, jak matice hustoty fungují pro více
systémů. Probereme produktové stavy a korelované stavy různého druhu, včetně provázaných stavů, a také
pojem redukovaného stavu, což je popis stavu izolované části složeného systému pomocí matice hustoty,
který lze vypočítat pomocí operace zvané parciální stopa. Než přejdeme k technickému obsahu samotné lekce,
je vhodné věnovat chvíli motivaci pro použití matic hustoty. Pomocí zjednodušené
formulace kvantových informací, která matice hustoty nezahrnuje, dokážeme popisovat kvantové algoritmy, jako je
Shorův faktorovací algoritmus, bez jakýchkoli obtíží. Proč se tedy vůbec zabývat maticemi hustoty
nebo touto obecnou formulací kvantových informací? Existuje pro to více důvodů. Za prvé, matice hustoty
reprezentují širší třídu kvantových stavů než kvantové stavové vektory, včetně kvantových stavů, kde máme neurčitost nebo
náhodnost. To je důležité, když chceme modelovat vliv šumu na kvantové výpočty,
například. Za druhé, pomocí matic hustoty dokážeme popisovat kvantové stavy izolovaných částí složených systémů,
například stavy systémů provázaných s jinými systémy, které se rozhodujeme dočasně ignorovat, jak jsem zmínil na začátku
lekce. To nelze ve zjednodušené formulaci kvantových
informací snadno ani přirozeně provést. Třetím důvodem je, že při použití matic hustoty klasické informace vlastně vznikají jako
speciální případ. Místo toho, abychom měli v podstatě analogii mezi pravděpodobnostními stavy a operacemi
na jedné straně a kvantovými stavovými vektory a unitárními operacemi na straně druhé, máme kvantové a klasické informace
popsané společně v rámci jednoho matematického formalismu, který je naprosto nezbytný pro matematické studium
kvantových informací. Pokud tedy myslíš vážně porozumění kvantovým informacím na matematické úrovni, je velmi
doporučeno, abys se naučil/a o maticích hustoty. Začněme definicí matic
hustoty. Pro účely definice předpokládejme, že X je systém a sigma je jeho klasická stavová množina, a vzpomeň si,
že když tuto terminologii používáme, předpokládáme, že Sigma je konečná a neprázdná, a jak vždy, mohli bychom zvolit
jiné názvy, kdybychom chtěli. Matice hustoty popisující stav systému X je matice s komplexními
číselnými prvky, jejichž řádky a sloupce jsou v korespondenci s její klasickou stavovou množinou, a pro jasnost
platí totéž pro řádky i sloupce zároveň. To znamená, že matice hustoty
jsou vždy čtvercové matice, a kromě toho, že jsou čtvercové, musí být splněny dvě podmínky,
ke kterým se zanedlouho dostaneme. Lidé obvykle používají určitá malá řecká písmena k pojmenování matic
hustoty. Rho je obvykle první volbou a další běžné volby jsou malá sigma a tau, které jsou zobrazeny
na obrazovce. Je to jen konvence, ale jako obvykle jsou takovéto konvence užitečné, protože dělají věci
snáze rozpoznatelnými. A teď si povíme o podmínkách nebo požadavcích, které musí matice hustoty splňovat, aby byly
platnými maticemi hustoty. Jsou to dvě podmínky, a to, co udělám, je nejprve je jednoduše vyjmenovat
a poté podrobněji vysvětlit, co znamenají. První podmínka je, že matice hustoty
musí mít jednotkovou stopu, jinými slovy stopa musí být rovna jedné. Druhá podmínka je, že
matice hustoty musí být pozitivně semidefinitní, a v obou případech máme stručné symbolické způsoby vyjádření
těchto dvou podmínek, které jsou na obrazovce. Nyní podrobněji probereme obě podmínky.
První podmínka se týká stopy, což je velmi důležitá funkce definovaná pro všechny čtvercové matice,
a je to jednoduše součet diagonálních prvků. Zde je rovnice, která to
výslovně vyjadřuje. O stopě je toho samozřejmě hodně co říci a proč je důležitá, ale zatím si jen všimněme
jedné velmi základní vlastnosti, a to, že je to lineární funkce. Další vlastnosti stopy se objeví a probereme je,
až budou potřeba, ale abychom se soustředili na matice hustoty, přejdeme k druhému požadavku, kterým je, že
matice hustoty jsou pozitivně semidefinitní. To je také důležitý koncept, který se vyskytuje v mnoha oblastech
WEBVTT
fyziky, chemie, optimalizace, strojového učení a dalších oborů, a lze ho vyjádřit několika různými, ale
ekvivalentními způsoby. Jedním ze způsobů, jak to vyjádřit, je říci, že matice rho je pozitivně semidefinitní, pokud existuje matice M
taková, že rho se rovná M dagger krát M, a ukáže se, že nezáleží na tom, zda požadujeme, aby M sama byla čtvercová
matice, nebo zda tento požadavek zrušíme. Dalším způsobem, jak vyjádřit, co znamená, že matice rho je pozitivně
semidefinitní, je říci, že rho je hermitovská, což znamená, že se rovná svému vlastnímu konjugovanému transposu, a všechna
její vlastní čísla jsou nezáporná reálná čísla. Obecně hermitovské matice mohou
mít pouze reálná vlastní čísla, ale ta mohou být záporná. Pokud však přidáme dodatečný požadavek, že žádné
vlastní číslo nesmí být záporné, dostaneme pozitivně semidefinitní matice. A mimochodem, pokud ti je dána
matice a chceš vědět, zda je pozitivně semidefinitní, můžeš to zjistit pomocí tohoto charakterizování. Je docela snadné
ověřit, zda matice je nebo není hermitovská, to lze posoudit na pohled. Je obtížnější vypočítat
vlastní čísla, ale to není příliš obtížné provést na počítači, protože existují velmi efektivní algoritmy pro to.
Poslední charakterizování, které zmíním, i když existují i jiná, je, že pro každý sloupcový vektor s, jehož
počet prvků souhlasí s počtem řádků a sloupců matice rho, platí nerovnost zobrazená na
obrazovce. Jinými slovy bra s krát rho krát ket s musí být nezáporné reálné
číslo. Není mimochodem zřejmé, že tato charakterizování jsou všechna ekvivalentní, ale jsou. A dovolte mi výslovně poznamenat, že
zápis, který běžně používáme k označení, že matice rho je pozitivně semidefinitní, vypadá jako rho je větší
nebo rovno nule, ale to je jen zkrácená notace a doslova neznamená, že rho je větší než
nebo rovno nule. Rho je matice, takže by to nedávalo smysl. A neznamená to
ani to, že každý prvek matice rho je větší nebo roven nule. Zejména existují pozitivně
semidefinitní matice, jejichž prvky nejsou všechny nezáporné, a existují matice, jejichž prvky jsou všechny nezáporné,
ale nejsou pozitivně semidefinitní. Myšlenka za touto notací je, že pozitivně semidefinitní
matice jsou jakési maticové analogy nezáporných reálných čísel, ale to je jen notace a to, co to znamená, je
přesně to, co jsme již probrali. Podívejme se nyní na několik příkladů, začínající příkladem pozitivně
semidefinitní matice. Ve skutečnosti je celkem snadné náhodně vygenerovat příklad
pozitivně semidefinitní matice tím, že jednoduše zvolíme matici M libovolně a pak vypočítáme M dagger krát
M. Například zde je matice M, která není nijak zvláštní, a vlastně jsem
tuto matici vygeneroval náhodně tím, že jsem nezávisle volil reálné a imaginární části prvků jako celá čísla mezi zápornou 9 a kladnou
9, takže jakékoli vzory nebo struktura zde jsou čistě náhodné. Vynásobením
konjugovaného transposu M k M dostaneme tuto matici, která je tedy pozitivně
semidefinitní. Samozřejmě existuje limit toho, kolik pochopení můžeme získat z náhodného příkladu, ale ukazuje některé
vlastnosti, které jsou obecně společné pozitivně semidefinitním maticím. Zejména si všimni,
že diagonální prvky, tedy ty podél čáry od levého horního rohu k pravému dolnímu rohu, jsou všechny nezáporná reálná
čísla, a navíc mimidiagonální prvky nejsou příliš velké ve srovnání s odpovídajícími diagonálními
prvky, tedy tím ve stejném řádku a tím ve stejném sloupci jako ten mimidiagonální prvek, na který se díváme.
K tomu příběhu je toho však více, a je důležité si uvědomit, že pozitivní semidefinitnost je
vlastností matice jako celku, a ne jen podmínkou pro jednotlivé prvky. Takže to byl příklad
pozitivně semidefinitní matice a velmi snadno si můžeš vygenerovat další příklady pomocí podobné
metodologie. Nyní se podívejme na několik příkladů matic hustoty, kde kromě podmínky pozitivní semidefinitnosti máme také, že stopa je
rovna jedné. Zde je několik příkladů matic hustoty 2x2. Stopa je rovna
jedné ve všech čtyřech případech a také vidíme, že jsou to hermitovské matice, takže pomocí druhého charakterizování
pozitivně semidefinitních matic zbývá jen ověřit, že všechna vlastní čísla jsou nezáporná.
Nechám to na tobě, pokud si přeješ to ověřit. Pro matice 2x2 není příliš obtížné vypočítat vlastní čísla ručně,
ale můžeš to také nechat na počítači. Například můžeš použít funkci eigvals v balíčku lineární algebry
pro Python. Matici hustoty také můžeme získat jednoduše tak, že vezmeme jakoukoli nulovou
pozitivně semidefinitní matici a vydělíme ji její stopou. Například zde je matice hustoty, kterou dostaneme
vydělením příkladu, který jsme viděli před chvílí, jeho stopou. Dělení stopou takto
vždy zachová vlastnost pozitivní semidefinitnosti a jistě získáme matici se stopou rovnou jedné díky tomu, že
stopa je lineární funkce. To je jen malá kolekce příkladů a více jich uvidíme, jak bude
lekce pokračovat. Dále věnujeme chvíli diskusi o interpretaci neboli
intuitivním významu matic hustoty. První věc, kterou je třeba přiznat, je, že může vypadat trochu neobvykle,
že stav systému reprezentujeme maticí a ne vektorem. Naproti tomu ve zjednodušené
formulaci kvantových informací používáme vektory k reprezentaci stavů, zatímco matice, konkrétně unitární matice,
reprezentují akce nebo operace. Tak prostě funguje matematika, a ačkoli si
matice vždy můžeš představit jako lineární zobrazení, typicky nepřiřazujeme přímý intuitivní
smysl lineárnímu zobrazení spojenému s danou maticí hustoty. Přesto, že matice hustoty jsou
skutečně matice, se ukáže jako kriticky důležitý aspekt, a to uvidíme,
jak budeme pokračovat. Ale abych krátce zmínil jeden příklad, vlastní čísla dané matice hustoty
se ukazují jako velmi důležitá, protože popisují, kolik náhodnosti nebo neurčitosti je inherentní stavu,
který tato matice hustoty popisuje. Jiný způsob, jak přemýšlet o maticích hustoty na intuitivní úrovni,
se zaměřuje na prvky těchto matic. Vzpomeň si, že řádky a sloupce matic hustoty jsou
v korespondenci s klasickými stavy jakéhokoli systému, o kterém mluvíme. Pro každý prvek tedy máme jeden
WEBVTT
klasický stav odpovídající řádku tohoto prvku a jeden klasický stav odpovídající sloupci tohoto
prvku. U diagonálních prvků jsou tyto dva klasické stavy totožné, a proto jsou diagonální prvky
zvláštní. Jeden způsob, jak lze diagonální prvky interpretovat, je, že jde o pravděpodobnosti, a konkrétně jde o
pravděpodobnosti, že by se příslušný klasický stav objevil, kdybychom provedli měření ve standardní bázi
na systému, jehož kvantový stav popisujeme. Co se týče mimidiagonálních prvků, na jedné straně máme jeden klasický stav odpovídající řádku
tohoto prvku a jiný klasický stav odpovídající sloupci tohoto prvku. Velmi neformálně řečeno
tyto prvky popisují míru, do jaké jsou tyto dva klasické stavy v kvantové superpozici, jakož i
relativní fázi mezi nimi. To může dávat větší smysl, jak bude lekce pokračovat a budeme se dívat
blíže na konkrétní příklady. Detaily nemusí být v tuto chvíli jasné, ale prosím, nenech se tím znepokojovat.
Je to zcela neformální a je to pouze intuitivní myšlenka, kterou si máš ponechat v záloze.
Dále se podíváme na spojení mezi maticemi hustoty a kvantovými stavovými vektory, které jsou sloupcové
vektory s euklidovskou normou rovnou jedné. Jen pro připomenutí matematické definice, předpokládejme, že máme
kvantový stavový vektor ψ, který reprezentuje stav nějakého konkrétního systému. Matice hustoty, která reprezentuje stejný
kvantový stav, je dána jako ket ψ krát bra ψ, jak je zde zobrazeno. Aby bylo jasno, indexy ψ
odpovídají nějakým způsobem klasickým stavům jakéhokoli systému, o němž mluvíme, a to bude přesně tatáž korespondence jako mezi
řádky a sloupci naší matice hustoty a klasickými stavy systému. Pokud si představíme, že existuje n
klasických stavů systému a přemýšlíme o sloupcových a řádkových vektorech jako o maticích, pak ket ψ je matice n krát 1
a bra ψ je matice 1 krát n. Takže když provedeme násobení, dostaneme matici n krát n.
To bude vždy pozitivně semidefinitní matice jen svou formou, a také bude mít stopu rovnou
jedné díky tomu, že ψ je jednotkový vektor, a to uvidíme podrobněji
zanedlouho. Kvantové stavy, které jsou reprezentovány maticemi hustoty tohoto tvaru, se nazývají čisté
stavy. Zde je několik příkladů. Nejprve uvažujme tento stav
zde, který je trochu jako stav plus, jenže prvek odpovídající klasickému stavu jedna je
imaginární. Pokud vypočítáme konjugovaný transpos, dostaneme záporné znaménko, protože komplexní konjugát čísla i je
záporné i. Pokud provedeme násobení, dostaneme matici zobrazenou zde na obrazovce. Je hermitovská, jak
hned vidíme pohledem, a má jedno vlastní číslo rovno jedné a jedno vlastní číslo rovno
nule, takže je pozitivně semidefinitní a její stopa je rovna jedné, takže je to matice hustoty,
jak se očekávalo. Matice hustoty odpovídající standardní bázi a bázi plus/minus můžeme vypočítat podobným způsobem a tyto matice hustoty
jsou zobrazeny zde. A zde je ještě jeden příklad kvantového stavového vektoru, který se náhodou
objevil dávno v první lekci série. Pokud vypočítáme konjugovaný transpos a poté vynásobíme,
dostaneme matici hustoty zobrazenou zde. Opět je hermitovská a má
stopu rovnou jedné. A pokud vypočítáš vlastní čísla, zjistíš, že opět má jedno vlastní číslo rovno jedné a jedno
vlastní číslo rovno nule. Mimochodem, to je společná charakteristika všech čistých stavů: vždy mají jedno vlastní číslo
rovno jedné a všechna ostatní vlastní čísla jsou nulová. Obecně platí, že pro zcela libovolný kvantový stavový
vektor ψ s libovolným počtem prvků, pokud vynásobíme ket ψ krát bra ψ, dostaneme
matici hustoty, která vypadá takto. Všimni si zejména, že diagonální prvky jsou vždy jedním z prvků
ψ vynásobeným vlastním komplexním konjugátem, který lze alternativně vyjádřit jako absolutní hodnota na druhou tohoto prvku, a to je
jeden způsob, jak vidět, že stopa bude vždy rovna jedné. Je to také v souladu s poznámkou, kterou jsem udělal dříve v lekci o tom, že
diagonální prvky matice hustoty nám říkají, jaké by byly pravděpodobnosti vidět každý možný klasický stav,
kdybychom provedli měření ve standardní bázi. A jedna závěrečná poznámka:
pro matice hustoty neexistuje žádný problém s globálními fázemi. Dva kvantové stavy jsou totožné právě tehdy, když jejich matice
hustoty jsou si rovny. Zejména předpokládejme, že máme dva kvantové stavové vektory ψ a φ, které jsou
ekvivalentní až na globální fázi, což znamená, že jeden z nich, řekněme φ, můžeme vyjádřit jako druhý vynásobený
nějakým komplexním číslem na jednotkové kružnici. Pokud vypočítáme reprezentaci matice hustoty φ, zjistíme,
že faktor globální fáze se vynásobí svým vlastním komplexním konjugátem, čímž dostaneme jedničku, takže
efektivně zmizí a zbyde nám přesně tatáž matice hustoty, jakou dostaneme z ψ. Je to tedy takový
pěkný bonus. Obecněji vzato, při práci s maticemi hustoty vůbec neexistuje žádný problém s ekvivalencí vůči globálním fázím.
To je v podstatě jen degenerace, která existuje, když k reprezentaci kvantových stavů používáme kvantové stavové vektory
místo matic hustoty. Matice hustoty mají klíčovou vlastnost, a to, že konvexní
kombinace matic hustoty reprezentují pravděpodobnostní nebo náhodné výběry kvantových
stavů. Jiný způsob, jak to říci, je, že matice hustoty lze smysluplně průměrovat dohromady, což
u kvantových stavových vektorů nelze dělat. Abychom to vysvětlili podrobněji, začněme situací, kdy
máme dvě matice hustoty rho a sigma reprezentující kvantové stavy nějakého systému. Představme si, že
systém je připraven ve stavu rho s pravděpodobností p pro nějakou volbu p mezi nulou a jednou, a jinak je systém
připraven ve stavu sigma. Například možná p je 1/2, takže si
můžeme představit, že někdo hodí spravedlivou mincí, a pokud padne orel, provede nějaký proces, který nechá systém ve
stavu rho, a jinak, pokud padne panna, provede jiný proces, který nechá systém ve
stavu sigma. Otázka nyní zní, jaký je stav systému, a aby bylo jasno,
zajímá nás stav systému izolovaně, bez ohledu na jakékoli jiné informace, které by mohly existovat o
tom, která příprava byla provedena. Například si představ, že nemáme přístup k minci nebo
paměti toho, kdo přípravou stavu prováděl. A odpověď na tuto otázku je, že je to jednoduše vážený průměr obou matic
WEBVTT
hustoty: p krát rho plus 1 minus p krát sigma. To je mimochodem zcela
analogické tomu, co bychom měli, kdyby rho a sigma nebyly matice hustoty, ale spíše pravděpodobnostní vektory
reprezentující pravděpodobnostní stavy. Takže to není nic šokujícího ani tajemného, ale spíše je to něco,
co je možná povědomé z teorie pravděpodobnosti. Tento druh průměrování provádíme neustále při výpočtu pravděpodobností a přemýšlení
o klasických náhodných výběrech. A pointa je, že to funguje i pro matice hustoty, ale pozor, nefunguje to
pro kvantové stavové vektory. To znamená, že obecně nemůžeš průměrovat dva kvantové stavové
vektory tímto způsobem a doufat, že dostaneš platný kvantový stavový vektor. Pokud to zkusíš, obvykle dostaneš vektor, který
nemá euklidovskou normu rovnou jedné. S maticemi hustoty však takovéto vážené průměry budou vždy
platné matice hustoty, a co je důležitější, matice hustoty, kterou dostaneš, bude smysluplným způsobem reprezentovat tento náhodný výběr.
To se zobecňuje na náhodné výběry, kde existuje více než dvě
alternativy. Konkrétně, máme-li m možných matic hustoty a pravděpodobnostní vektor s m prvky, jeden
pro každou matici hustoty, a systém je připraven v každém možném stavu s odpovídající pravděpodobností,
pak vážený průměr těchto matic hustoty popisuje výsledný stav systému. A mimochodem, když
odkazujeme na konvexní kombinaci matic hustoty, máme tím na mysli právě toto. Konvexní kombinace je jednoduše lineární
kombinace, kde koeficienty tvoří pravděpodobnostní vektor. To bude vždy matice hustoty
a jednoduchý a stručný způsob, jak to říci matematickými termíny, je, že množina všech matic hustoty
odpovídajících danému systému je konvexní množina. Takže řekněme, že máme m kvantových stavových
vektorů ψ_0 až ψ_ spolu s pravděpodobnostmi p_0 až p_, které dohromady tvoří
pravděpodobnostní vektor, a systém je připraven ve stavu ψ_k s pravděpodobností p_k pro každé k. Výsledný stav
systému pak popisuje matice hustoty zobrazená zde na obrazovce. Zejména neprůměrujeme
samotné kvantové stavové vektory, nýbrž průměrujeme odpovídající matice hustoty. Obecně stav takového druhu nebude mít reprezentaci jako jediný kvantový stavový
vektor, ledaže by se dělo něco triviálního, například všechny kvantové stavové vektory jsou ekvivalentní vůči globální fázi nebo všechny kromě jednoho
pravděpodobnosti jsou nulové. Nezískáme čistý kvantový stav takovým procesem, ale spíše získáme to, čemu se říká
smíšený kvantový stav, kde je inherentně přítomna určitá neurčitost. Podívejme se na jednoduchý
příklad. Předpokládejme, že máme qubit a s pravděpodobností 1/2 je qubit připraven ve stavu nula a jinak
je připraven ve stavu plus. Zde je matice hustoty, kterou dostaneme průměrováním, jak jsem
popsal. Vypočítáme matice hustoty odpovídající dvěma možným stavům, vynásobíme odpovídajícími pravděpodobnostmi a výsledky sečteme.
Co dostaneme, je skutečně matice hustoty: je hermitovská, stopa se rovná jedné
a pokud vypočítáš vlastní čísla této matice, dostaneš dvě kladná reálná čísla, která náhodou jsou dvě čísla, jež by ti
už teď měla být povědomá: kosinus na druhou z π/8 a sinus na druhou z π/8, neboli přibližně 0,85 a
0,15. Neexistuje žádná reprezentace stavu jako jediného kvantového stavového vektoru, není to čistý stav. Dále se podíváme na jednu
konkrétní matici hustoty, která reprezentuje kvantový stav jednoho qubitu, známou jako úplně smíšený
stav. Tento stav se vyskytuje často, takže je dobré mít pro něj název, a je to také dobrý příklad, protože
ilustruje důležitou vlastnost matic hustoty. Ve skutečnosti existuje analogicky definovaný úplně smíšený stav pro jakýkoli
systém, ale nyní se zaměříme na tento stav pro jeden qubit, jen abychom si věci
zjednodušili. Předpokládejme, že náhodně nastavíme stav qubitu na stav nula nebo stav jedna, každý s
pravděpodobností rovnou 1/2, podobně jako uniformní náhodný bit. Reprezentaci matice hustoty tohoto
stavu vypočítáme obvyklým způsobem: vezmeme průměr dvou reprezentací matic hustoty těchto stavů. Zde je vidět,
jak to vypadá v maticové formě, a to, co dostaneme, je jednotková matice vydělená
dvěma. Tento stav je znám jako úplně smíšený stav a v podstatě reprezentuje úplnou nebo maximální
neurčitost ohledně qubitu, stejně jako uniformní pravděpodobnostní vektor reprezentuje maximální neurčitost v
klasickém pravděpodobnostním prostředí. Obecně pro libovolný systém je úplně smíšený stav ten,
který dostaneme uniformním výběrem stavu standardní báze, a reprezentace matice hustoty bude
jednotková matice vydělená dimenzí, nebo ekvivalentně počtem klasických stavů tohoto
systému. V tuto chvíli je to jen terminologie, ale pokud trochu změníme nastavení, uvidíme důležitou vlastnost
matic hustoty. Konkrétně předpokládejme, že změníme postup a
místo standardních bázových stavů nula a jedna dosadíme stavy plus a minus. Tentokrát začínáme s
výrazem zobrazeným na obrazovce, ale pokud projdeme výpočtem, dostaneme přesně tutéž
matici hustoty: je to jednotková matice vydělená dvěma, takže je to tentýž stav jako předtím,
úplně smíšený stav. To je, jak se říká, funkce a ne chyba. Oba postupy jsou ve skutečnosti
různé, ale pokud máš pouze výsledný qubit, neexistuje žádný fyzikální způsob, jak je případně rozlišit,
dokonce ani v statistickém smyslu. Například pokud bys provedl/a měření ve standardní bázi na tomto qubitu
po provedení prvního postupu, dostaneš výsledek nula s pravděpodobností 1/2 a výsledek jedna s pravděpodobností 1/2. Ale dostaneš
přesně stejné výsledné pravděpodobnosti i pro druhý postup. A totéž platí pro jakýkoli jiný test, který by sis
mohl/a vymyslet, za předpokladu, že testuješ pouze samotný qubit. Obecně matice hustoty nepopisují, jak byl systém
připraven, ale říkají ti jen to, co se stane, pokud se systémem budeš něco dělat, ať už
provádíš operace nebo měření. A ve skutečnosti jsou matice hustoty v tomto ohledu dokonalé:
pokud dvě různé alternativy vedou ke stejné matici hustoty, nelze je rozlišit
ani statisticky. Pokud jsou však obě matice hustoty různé, existuje způsob, jak je rozlišit, ne
nutně jednoznačně, ale v statistickém smyslu. Když používáme obecnou formulaci kvantových
informací, klasické informace v podstatě vycházejí jako speciální případ, a nyní vysvětlím, jak to
WEBVTT
funguje. Konkrétně uvidíme, jak lze pravděpodobnostní stavy reprezentovat maticemi
hustoty. Začněme klasickými stavy, počínaje jednoduchým
příkladem. Zde jsou reprezentace matic hustoty standardních bázových stavů nula a jedna
qubitu. Tyto stavy přiřazujeme klasickým stavům 0 a 1, takže si tyto matice hustoty můžeme představovat jako
reprezentace těchto stavů. To je velmi jednoduché a snadno to zobecníme.
Pokud máme systém, jehož klasická stavová množina je Sigma, pak klasický stav a je reprezentován nebo
spojen s maticí hustoty ket a bra a. Tato matice má jednu jedničku na
diagonálním prvku, jehož řádek a sloupec odpovídají klasickému stavu a, a každý jiný prvek je
nulový. Pravděpodobnostní stavy jsou reprezentovány konvexními kombinacemi matic tohoto tvaru, což je přirozené
s ohledem na to, co víme o maticích hustoty a jejich fungování, konkrétně to, že konvexní kombinace matic hustoty reprezentují náhodné nebo
pravděpodobnostní výběry kvantových stavů. Například předpokládejme, že
máme systém X, jehož klasická stavová množina obsahuje celá čísla od 0 do n minus 1 pro nějaké kladné celé číslo n.
Samozřejmě, předpokladem, že naše klasická stavová množina má tento tvar, se neztratí příliš mnoho nebo nic ze
zobecnění. Kdybychom měli jinou klasickou stavovou množinu, mohli bychom jednoduše přejmenovat klasické stavy tímto způsobem a je to
často docela výhodné předpokládat, že naše klasické stavové množiny vypadají takto, z velké části proto, že to usnadňuje psát věci explicitně pomocí
vektorů a matic. Předpokládejme, že máme pravděpodobnostní stav systému X
reprezentovaný pravděpodobnostním vektorem obvyklým způsobem. Tento pravděpodobnostní stav můžeme přiřadit matici
hustoty, jak je zobrazeno na obrazovce. Vezmeme vážený průměr matic hustoty odpovídajících
různým klasickým stavům a to, co dostaneme, je diagonální matice hustoty. Konkrétně vidíme pravděpodobnosti
na diagonále této matice a každý jiný prvek je roven nule. To je samozřejmě matice hustoty,
to očekáváme, ale můžeme to také odvodit přímo: je to hermitovská matice, její stopa
je rovna jedné, protože pravděpodobnosti se sčítají na jednu, a v případě diagonální matice jsou vlastní čísla diagonální
prvky, které jsou všechny nezáporné, protože jde o pravděpodobnosti. Všimni si také, že každá
diagonální matice hustoty, tedy taková, jejíž mimidiagonální prvky jsou všechny nulové, musí vypadat takto. Stručně řečeno,
pravděpodobnostní stavy lze přiřadit diagonálním maticím hustoty. Všimni si mimochodem, že to je v souladu s
neformální interpretací prvků matic hustoty, kterou jsem zmínil na začátku lekce. Zejména nic není v
kvantové superpozici, je to v podstatě jen klasická náhodnost, a odpovídajícím způsobem jsou všechny mimidiagonální
prvky nulové. Dříve v této sérii jsme probrali spektrální větu, a to konkrétně
pro unitární matice v kontextu fázové estimace. Spektrální věta je ale
obecnější, což znamená, že nám říká něco o širší třídě matic než jen unitárních.
Konkrétně se vztahuje na třídu matic nazývanou normální matice, která zahrnuje všechny hermitovské matice, jakož
i unitární matice. Co nyní uděláme, je podíváme se na jiné vyjádření této věty, tentokrát se zaměřením pouze na
pozitivně semidefinitní matice, a pak uvidíme, že nám říká něco velmi zajímavého a kriticky důležitého o maticích hustoty.
Předpokládejme, že p je jakákoli pozitivně semidefinitní matice, takže to zahrnuje jakoukoli matici hustoty, jakož i jakoukoli
pozitivně semidefinitní matici, která náhodou nemá stopu rovnou jedné. p je pozitivně semidefinitní, takže musí být
čtvercová, jinými slovy n krát n pro nějakou volbu n, a toto číslo n budeme potřebovat, takže nechť n je
zvoleno přiměřeně, nebo jiným způsobem, jak to vše říci, je předpokládat, že p je n krát n. Co nám věta říká v tomto případě, je, že
musí existovat ortonormální báze vektorů, které nazveme ψ_0 až ψ_, spolu s nezápornými reálnými
čísly λ_0 až λ_ takovými, že p lze vyjádřit, jak je zobrazeno
zde na obrazovce. Jinými slovy, pokud vynásobíme každé λ_k krát ket ψ_k krát bra ψ_k a poté
sečteme přes všechna k od 0 do n minus 1, dostaneme p. Toto se nazývá spektrální
rozklad p. Každé λ_k je nutně vlastním číslem p a každé ψ je jednotkový vlastní vektor p
odpovídající tomuto vlastnímu číslu. Pokud se podíváš zpět na lekci 7 o fázové estimaci, najdeš podobnou větu
pro unitární matice. Tam jsou vlastní čísla komplexní čísla na jednotkové kružnici, a ne nezáporná reálná
čísla, ale jinak je to táž myšlenka, a to jsou skutečně jen dva speciální případy obecnější věty, známé jako
spektrální věta. Nefunguje pro každou matici, matice musí komutovat se svým
vlastním konjugovaným transposem, a to je to, co znamená, že matice je normální. Ale ve skutečnosti to vždy platí
jak pro unitární matice, tak pro pozitivně semidefinitní matice a obecněji pro hermitovské matice, kde
budeme mít vždy reálná vlastní čísla, ale ne nutně nezáporná. Takže to bylo vyjádření
spektrální věty jen pro pozitivně semidefinitní matice, a nyní se podívejme, co nám říká o maticích hustoty.
Co nám říká, je, že pro libovolnou matici hustoty n krát n můžeme tuto matici vždy vyjádřit jako konvexní
kombinaci n čistých stavů, a navíc můžeme těchto n čistých stavů vzít jako
ortogonální. To plyne celkem přímo z věty spolu se základním faktem lineární algebry, kterým je, že
součet vlastních čísel jakékoli matice je vždy roven stopě této matice. Jinými slovy, vše, co vlastně
děláme, je přejmenování vlastních čísel na p_0 až p_ a poté pozorování, že když to uděláme a
shromáždíme tato vlastní čísla do n-dimenzionálního vektoru, nutně dostaneme pravděpodobnostní vektor, protože musí být všechna nezáporná a jejich součet se rovná
stopě rho, která je rovna jedné, protože rho je matice hustoty. Takže to je docela jednoduché, ale je to
konceptuálně velmi zásadní. Co nám říká, je, že každá matice hustoty, bez ohledu na to, jak komplikovaná může vypadat, by mohla vzniknout tak, že
nejprve zvolíme ortonormální bázi jakéhokoli systému, o němž mluvíme, a poté náhodně vybereme kvantový stav z této báze podle nějaké volby pravděpodobností.
a poté náhodně vybereme kvantový stav z této báze podle nějaké volby pravděpodobností.
Pokud není hned na první pohled zřejmé, proč je to zajímavé nebo důležité, to nevadí, ale tento
WEBVTT
fakt velmi často používáme při uvažování o maticích hustoty, a ve skutečnosti vyjádření dané matice hustoty
tímto způsobem je často první věcí, kterou uděláme, když ji chceme pochopit
lépe. Zde je příklad. Vzpomeň si na matici hustoty, se kterou jsme přišli dříve, kde jsme náhodně volili mezi
stavem nula a stavem plus, každý s pravděpodobností 1/2, která, jak jsme vypočítali, má matici hustoty, jež
vypadá takto. Stav nula a stav plus nejsou ortogonální, takže to není
spektrální rozklad. Pokud ale vypočítáme jeden, což lze provést na počítači nebo ručně v takovém případě, pak
dostaneme toto vyjádření naší matice hustoty, kde vlastní čísla jsou tato čísla, která se stále opakují,
a kde odpovídající vlastní vektory lze zvolit, jak je zobrazeno zde dole na obrazovce. A opět jsme tyto vektory viděli dříve, například v
kontextu hry CHSH v lekci čtyři. Takže to je zajímavé. Podle
původního vyjádření je tento stav tím, co dostaneme uniformním výběrem mezi dvěma stavy: stavem nula a
stavem plus. Ale ve skutečnosti dostaneme přesně tutéž matici hustoty náhodným výběrem mezi dvěma čistými
stavy, ale s velmi silným sklonem k jednomu z nich: přibližně 85 % pro první z nich a pouze přibližně 15 % pro
druhý. Takže v jistém smyslu je ve skutečnosti inherentní náhodnost stavu podstatně menší, než se původně mohlo
zdát. Existuje velmi pěkný geometrický způsob přemýšlení o kvantových stavech jednoho qubitu a jejich vizualizace, známý
jako Blochova sféra. Funguje pouze pro jednotlivé qubity. Pro systémy se třemi
nebo více klasickými stavy, včetně dvou nebo více qubitů dohromady, to již nefunguje, takže je to docela omezené, ale
přesto je to skvělý způsob, jak přemýšlet o stavech jednoho qubitu. Mohlo to být zavedeno dávno
v první lekci série o jednotlivých systémech, ale není to skutečně nezbytné pro pochopení fungování kvantových informací, a také to má
velmi pěknou spojitost s maticemi hustoty, takže přirozeně patří do této lekce. A ve skutečnosti to vysvětlím
trochu jinak, než je možná nejběžnější způsob výkladu, a to použitím matic hustoty k
efektivnímu odvození. Takže pokud již Blochovu sféru znáš, toto vysvětlení se může trochu lišit od způsobu, jakým ses ji
poprvé naučil/a, ale nakonec by mělo být samozřejmě ekvivalentní. Začneme přemýšlením o
možných čistých stavech qubitu, nejprve reprezentovaných kvantovými stavovými
vektory. Vůči globální fázi lze každý kvantový stavový vektor qubitu vyjádřit, jak je
zobrazeno zde na obrazovce. Abychom byli přesní, máme dvě reálná čísla θ a φ, o kterých budeme přemýšlet
jako o úhlech vyjádřených v radiánech. První číslo θ leží mezi 0 a π, nebo ekvivalentně je to
úhel mezi 0 a 180°, a druhé číslo φ leží mezi 0 a 2π, včetně 0, ale bez 2π,
takže to je jakýkoli úhel mezi 0 a 360°. Nultý prvek našeho vektoru je
kosinus z θ/2, což je reálné číslo mezi 0 a 1, a konkrétně je nutně nezáporné.
A první prvek našeho vektoru je e na i krát φ krát sinus z θ/2, který může být
jakékoli komplexní číslo na nebo uvnitř komplexní jednotkové kružnice. Toto je vždy jednotkový vektor, neboli
jinými slovy platný kvantový stavový vektor, a pro jakýkoli daný kvantový stavový vektor qubitu vždy najdeme
vektor tohoto tvaru, který je ekvivalentní tomuto vektoru vůči globální fázi. Konkrétně vždy
můžeme daný vektor vynásobit globální fází, aby nultý prvek byl nezáporné reálné číslo, zvolíme θ,
které nám tento prvek dá, a pak vybereme φ tak, aby odpovídal prvnímu prvku. Velikost prvního prvku bude
vždy nutně souhlasit se sinusem z θ/2 z předpokladu, že jsme začali s jednotkovým
vektorem. Není přesně pravda, že θ a φ jsou jednoznačně určeny jakýmkoli kvantovým stavovým vektorem, se kterým jsme začali,
ale téměř ano. Vždy bude existovat jedinečná hodnota θ mezi nulou a π, která funguje,
a obvykle existuje jedinečná hodnota φ, která funguje, ale ve dvou speciálních případech to tak není. Konkrétně, pokud jsme začali se
standardním bázovým stavem, pak θ bude buď nula nebo π, a v obou případech nezáleží vůbec na φ, je to
zcela irelevantní. Když je θ nula, kosinus z θ/2 je 1 a sinus z θ/2
je nula, takže násobíme e na i krát φ nulou, takže na φ nezáleží.
A pokud je θ rovno π, pak tentokrát je kosinus nula a sinus je jedna, takže máme e na i krát φ krát ket 1, ale tyto
vektory jsou všechny ekvivalentní vůči globální fázi, takže opět nezáleží na φ. Pokud však θ leží řádně
mezi nulou a π, pak vždy bude existovat jedinečná hodnota φ, která funguje. Mimochodem, tato možná
degenerace v hodnotě φ pro dva speciální případy bude dávat dokonalý smysl, až za
chvilku uvidíme geometrický obraz. Nyní vypočítejme matici hustoty spojenou se stavovým vektorem tvaru, který jsme právě
identifikovali. Takže to bude čistý stav qubitu. Abychom to udělali, vynásobíme vektor
jeho konjugovaným transposem jako obvykle, a na obrazovce je vyjádření matice, kterou dostaneme výpočtem konjugovaného
transposu a provedením násobení. Nyní, stejně jako každá matice 2x2,
existuje jedinečný způsob, jak tuto matici vyjádřit jako lineární kombinaci Pauliho matic,
včetně jednotkové matice. Konkrétně tuto matici dostaneme tak, že zvolíme koeficienty
Pauliho matic, jak je zobrazeno zde na obrazovce. Do jmenovatele dáváme dvě, protože to
způsobí, že vše krásně vychází. Nic nás to nenutí dělat, ale můžeme to udělat a je to užitečné. Ale kromě
této kosmetické volby zde není žádná svoboda: toto je jediný způsob, jak dostat tuto matici jako lineární kombinaci Pauliho matic.
Je to proto, že Pauliho matice, včetně jednotkové, tvoří bázi vektorového prostoru všech matic 2x2. Jedním způsobem,
jak ověřit správnost tohoto vyjádření, je použít některé základní trigonometrické identity, a pokud se na chvíli
odsunutím dostaneme stranou, vidíme některé identity, které to zajistí. Takže pokud máš chuť, zastav video nebo
udělej screenshot a zkus z prvního vyjádření matice hustoty nahoře odvodit druhé dole. Stručně řečeno, každý čistý stav
qubitu vyjádřený jako matice hustoty lze zapsat jako lineární kombinaci Pauliho matic, jak je zobrazeno na
WEBVTT
obrazovce, pro θ mezi 0 a π a φ mezi 0 a 2π. Všimni si, že máme přesně tutéž
degeneraci jako předtím, a to, že φ je irelevantní, když je θ buď nula nebo π, a tentokrát to vidíme
jasněji, protože sinus z θ je v těchto dvou případech nulový, a jinak ne. Za zmínku stojí,
že v tomto vzorci se θ objevuje jako argument funkcí sinus a kosinus, a ne θ/2 jako v původní kvantové stavové
vektorové verzi. Je to proto, že jsme použili trigonometrické identity, z nichž první tři jsou v podstatě
přeuspořádání tzv. vzorců pro dvojnásobný úhel. Takže úhel se efektivně zdvojnásobí. A nyní jsme konečně připraveni
mluvit o samotné Blochově sféře. Zaměřme se na tři koeficienty ne-identitových Pauliho
matic v čitateli vyjádření naší matice hustoty. Ignorujeme tedy dvě ve
jmenovateli. Ignorujeme také jednotkovou matici, protože koeficient u ní se nikdy nemění. To se děje proto, že tento
koeficient je určen stopou jakékoli matice, kterou vyjadřujeme, a matice hustoty mají vždy stopu rovnou
jedné. Nyní si představ, že máme tři osy označené x, y a z, orientované podle
tzv. pravidla pravé ruky, a uvažuj bod, jehož souřadnice odpovídají třem koeficientům. A aby bylo jasno, jde o
obyčejný třírozměrný prostor, kde souřadnice jsou vždy reálná čísla. Souřadnice x odpovídá koeficientu matice sigma X Pauliho
v čitateli našeho vyjádření, která je vždy reálné číslo, protože matice hustoty jsou hermitovské,
a totéž platí pro y a z. Zjistíme, že tento bod,
který dostaneme, leží vždy na jednotkové sféře, jinými slovy na sféře s poloměrem rovným
jedné. Konkrétně je to bod, který dostaneme, když začneme v bodě, kde kladná osa z protíná sféru,
o němž si můžeme myslet jako o severním pólu, natočíme se dolů k kladné ose x o úhel θ a poté
natočíme k kladné ose y, neboli jinými slovy na východ, o úhel φ. V tomto kontextu se úhel θ
nazývá polárním úhlem, což je snadno zapamatovatelné, protože začíná u pólu, a φ se nazývá azimutálním
úhlem. Dohromady tyto dva úhly představují sférické souřadnice pro body na jednotkové sféře. A pokud
bys chtěl/a, mohl/a bys také nechat poloměr měnit, aby reprezentoval libovolné body v třírozměrném prostoru, ale zde se zaměřujeme na body na
jednotkové sféře, kde je poloměr roven jedné. Také si můžeš θ představit jako zeměpisnou šířku, jenže jdeme
od 0 do 180° od severního k jižnímu pólu, a ne od plus/minus 90° od rovníku. A φ reprezentuje
zeměpisnou délku, kde v podstatě definujeme nultý poledník jako poledník, který protíná kladnou
osu x. Mimochodem, pokud si jako já pletete, co je šířka a co délka, může být užitečné si zapamatovat,
že délka odpovídá intervalu, který je delší, tedy 2π oproti
π. Každopádně bod, který dostaneme na jednotkové sféře z našeho stavového vektoru qubitu ψ přemýšlením o souřadnicích tímto
způsobem, je blochova sférová reprezentace kvantového stavu odpovídajícího ψ. A když přemýšlíme o celé
třírozměrné jednotkové sféře tímto způsobem, dostaneme Blochovu sféru. Geometricky je to jen jednotková
sféra v obyčejném třírozměrném prostoru, ale to ve skutečnosti je geometrie stavů qubitu.
Existuje dokonalá bijekce: každý čistý stav qubitu odpovídá jedinečnému bodu na sféře
a každý bod na sféře reprezentuje jedinečný stav qubitu vůči globální fázi. Při práci s
kvantovými stavovými vektory má tato korespondence mimochodem i jiné názvy, někdy se ji říká Poincaréova sféra,
ale v kontextu kvantových informací se obecně označuje jako Blochova sféra. Všimni si, že nyní vidíme
degeneraci v úhlu φ docela jasně, protože délka nemá smysl na severním a jižním pólu. Ale kromě
pólů má každý bod na Zemi jedinečné souřadnice z hlediska šířky a délky, a totéž se děje zde. Takže takto
Blochova sféra obecně funguje. Podívejme se nyní na několik konkrétních příkladů stavů qubitů a
kde leží na Blochově sféře. Začneme se standardní bází. Jsou to body, které dostaneme,
když polární úhel θ je nula pro stav nula a π pro stav jedna. Jsou to dva případy, kdy je
azimutální úhel φ irelevantní, jak jsem již probral. Odpovídající matice hustoty také můžeme vyjádřit jako lineární
kombinace Pauliho matic, a z obou způsobů usuzujeme, že tyto dva stavy odpovídají severnímu a
jižnímu pólu Blochovy sféry. Stav nula je nahoře a stav jedna je
dole. Dále najděme stavy plus a minus na Blochově sféře. Opět si můžeme vybrat mezi
kvantovými stavovými vektory nebo maticemi hustoty. Pro kvantové stavové vektory tentokrát musí být polární úhel θ roven π/2,
aby nultý prvek byl 1/√2. Azimutální úhel φ musí být nula
pro stav plus, protože první prvek je pro stav plus kladný, a musí být π neboli 180° pro stav minus,
protože ten je v tomto případě záporný. Takže tyto dva body leží na
rovníku Blochovy sféry. Stav plus je tam, kde kladná osa x protíná sféru, a stav minus je na opačné straně, kde
záporná osa x protíná sféru. Ekvivalentně to vidíme i z vyjádření Pauliho matic pro
odpovídající matice hustoty, kde souřadnice y a z jsou obě nulové, zatímco souřadnice x jsou kladná a záporná
jednička. Dalším příkladem je báze plus i / minus i, která je podobná bázi plus/minus, jenže první prvek je také násoben
číslem i, tedy imaginární jednotkou. Stav plus i jsme viděli dříve v lekci a stav minus i je definován
analogicky. Polární úhel θ je stejný jako pro stavy plus a minus: π/2.
A tentokrát potřebujeme zvolit azimutální úhel φ tak, abychom dostali i a záporné i místo 1 a záporné 1.
A π/2 a 3π/2 jsou správné volby, které toho dosáhnou. Opět se také můžeme podívat na
popis těchto stavů pomocí matic hustoty, a věci jsou docela podobné předchozím dvěma příkladům, jenže tentokrát je to matice Pauliho y místo
z nebo x. Takže na Blochově sféře leží tyto dva stavy tam, kde osa y
protíná sféru. A pokud si věci trochu uklidíme, vidíme jasněji, jak šest stavů, které jsme právě probrali,
spolu navzájem souvisí. Pro ještě jeden příklad, nebo vlastně třídu příkladů, uvažujme
stavové vektory qubitů, které se objevily dříve a v lekci čtyři, kde nultý prvek je kosinus z α pro nějaké reálné číslo α a první
WEBVTT
prvek je sinus z α. Mimochodem, naši pozornost můžeme omezit na hodnoty α mezi nulou a π, protože jakákoli
jiná hodnota α nám dá vektor, který je ekvivalentní vůči globální fázi takovému, kde α je v tomto
rozsahu. Pokud vypočítáme matice hustoty spojené s těmito stavy, vyjádřené jako lineární kombinace Pauliho matic,
dostaneme vyjádření, které je zobrazeno zde na obrazovce. Tento výpočet zde není uveden, ale to je to, co bys měl/a
dostat, pokud si tím projdeš. A zjistíme, že tyto stavy tvoří tzv. velký kruh, který prochází
póly: konkrétně začínající od severního pólu, když je α nula, putující dolů hlavním poledníkem a
dosahující jižního pólu, když je α rovno π/2, a poté zpět k severnímu pólu na opačné straně sféry, jak α roste od π/2 do
π. A to vše dává smysl, protože zaprvé jsou to reálné vektory, takže imaginární část je vždy nulová, a za
druhé se úhel α na Blochově sféře efektivně zdvojnásobí, a to lze opět vysvětlit použitím
vzorců pro dvojnásobný úhel. Viděli jsme, že Blochova sféra poskytuje velmi pěknou geometrickou reprezentaci čistých stavů
qubitu, kde každý bod na sféře odpovídá jedinečnému čistému stavu qubitu a naopak.
Když hovoříme o Blochově kouli, mluvíme o všech bodech na Blochově sféře, jakož i o bodech
obsažených uvnitř ní. Body v interiéru Blochovy koule také odpovídají stavům qubitu,
konkrétně stavům, které nejsou čisté. Jinými slovy jde o stavy qubitů, které lze reprezentovat maticemi hustoty, ale ne stavovými vektory qubitů.
Základním aspektem Blochovy koule a způsobu, jakým vnitřní body reprezentují nečisté stavy, je to, že
konvexní kombinace bodů uvnitř Blochovy koule odpovídají konvexním kombinacím matic hustoty.
Intuitivně to znamená, že geometrie nadále funguje dokonale i uvnitř Blochovy
koule. Podívejme se na pár příkladů, počínaje středovým bodem Blochovy koule, který reprezentuje
úplně smíšený stav. Úplně smíšený stav se získá průměrováním stavů nula a jedna, což je v souladu s tím,
že střed sféry leží přesně v polovině vzdálenosti mezi severním a jižním pólem, a ve skutečnosti leží v polovině vzdálenosti mezi libovolnými dvěma antipodálními body,
jako jsou stavy plus a minus a stavy plus i a minus i. Antipodální body na Blochově sféře vždy odpovídají
ortogonálním čistým stavům, a to odhaluje nebo odráží, že úplně smíšený stav vždy lze zapsat
jako průměr dvou libovolných ortogonálních čistých stavů qubitu. Jiný způsob, jak to vidět, je
přemýšlet o reprezentaci úplně smíšeného stavu pomocí Pauliho matic. Aby to fungovalo, musíme nastavit
koeficienty u všech tří ne-identitových Pauliho matic na nulu, a odpovídající bod uvnitř
Blochovy koule leží přímo ve středu, na počátku. A mimochodem, přemýšlení o reprezentacích matic hustoty pomocí Pauliho
matic takto ve skutečnosti docela jasně ukazuje, že konvexní kombinace bodů Blochovy koule odpovídají konvexním
kombinacím matic hustoty. Pokud vezmeme průměr nebo vážený průměr matic hustoty a
vyjádříme vše v termínech lineárních kombinací Pauliho matic, pak samozřejmě jen průměrujeme odpovídající body, protože vše
je lineární v těchto třech koeficientech. Pro ještě jeden příklad uvažujme průměr stavu nula
a stavu plus, který jsme viděli dříve v lekci. Vypočítali jsme reprezentaci matice hustoty, která je zobrazena na
obrazovce, a máme, že bod leží v interiéru Blochovy koule v polovině vzdálenosti mezi stavem nula a stavem plus.
Viděli jsme také, že tuto matici hustoty můžeme vyjádřit jinak na základě jejího spektrálního rozkladu, a
to je opět v souladu s diagramem a předchozími příklady. A tím je uzavřena
diskuse o Blochově sféře a Blochově kouli. Lidé se často ptají, zda existuje Blochova sféra nebo koule pro systémy se třemi
nebo více klasickými stavy, a bohužel odpověď zní: ne úplně. Vždy si kvantové
stavy systému můžeme představit v geometrických pojmech podobných Blochově kouli a dostaneme konvexní těleso v reálném vektorovém
prostoru. Pokud ale máme tři nebo více klasických stavů, nebude to kulové. Například pokud máme
přesně tři klasické stavy, neboli qutrit, dostaneme konvexní těleso v osmirozměrném
prostoru, ale krajní body tohoto tělesa, které odpovídají čistým kvantovým stavům qutritu, budou jen
čtyřrozměrné. Pokud si dokážeš vizualizovat čtyřrozměrnou varietou v osmirozměrném prostoru a jaksi ji přibalit, abys dostal/a konvexní
těleso, a považuješ to za užitečný způsob přemýšlení o qutritu, tak jen do toho. Je to zajímavé
přemýšlet, ale není to koule, je to komplikovanější. V závěrečné části lekce si krátce povíme,
jak matice hustoty fungují pro více systémů. Matice hustoty mohou reprezentovat stavy více systémů, a to
funguje zcela analogicky jako kvantové stavové vektory. Konkrétně, stejně jako ve zjednodušené formulaci kvantových
informací, můžeme nahlížet na více systémů dohromady jako na jediný složený
systém. Tentokrát jsou jak řádky, tak sloupce matic hustoty, které reprezentují stavy více systémů,
v korespondenci s kartézským součinem klasických stavových množin jednotlivých systémů. Například můžeme uvažovat
reprezentace matic hustoty čtyř Bellových stavů, které dostaneme přesně tak, jak jsme to dělali pro jiné kvantové
stavové vektory dříve v lekci: vynásobením stavových vektorů jejich konjugovanými transposy, a výsledky jsou zobrazeny zde na
obrazovce. V podstatě na konceptuální úrovni není nic nového, ačkoli zanedlouho uvidíme, že existují nové
věci, které s maticemi hustoty pro více systémů můžeme dělat. Pojmy nezávislosti a
korelace se přenášejí z kvantových stavových vektorů do matic hustoty, a konkrétně zjistíme, že tenzorové součiny
matic hustoty reprezentují nezávislost mezi systémy. Používáme stejnou terminologii,
jakou jsme používali pro kvantové stavové vektory. Například pokud máme systém X připravený ve stavu rho a systém Y,
který je nezávisle připraven ve stavu sigma, pak stav páru XY dohromady je dán tenzorový součinem
rho a sigma. Tomu říkáme produktový stav, a to se přirozeně zobecňuje na více než dva
systémy. Matice hustoty, které nelze vyjádřit jako produktové stavy, reprezentují korelace mezi systémy, a to
je podobné kvantovým stavovým vektorům. Jak se ale ukazuje, existují různé typy korelací, které mohou vznikat při použití matic hustoty, dokonce i pro
jen dva systémy. Naproti tomu pro kvantové stavové vektory existuje skutečně pouze jeden typ korelace, který můžeme mít,
a to je provázanost. Jinak řečeno, korelace a provázanost jsou synonyma pro kvantové stavové vektory, ale
WEBVTT
pro matice hustoty to neplatí. Zde jsou věci zajímavější. Například pomocí matic hustoty můžeme popisovat
korelované klasické stavy. Zde je příklad matice hustoty reprezentující klasický náhodný
bit sdílený mezi Alicí a Bobem. Vždy mají tentýž klasický stav, nula nebo jedna, a pravděpodobnost je
1/2 pro každou z možností. Toto není provázaný stav, provázanost je neklasická, ale
je to korelovaný stav. Dalším příkladem je pojem ansámblu kvantových stavů,
o němž si můžeš myslet jako o pravděpodobnostním rozdělení nad konečnou množinou kvantových stavů. Konkrétně si představ, že
máme m matic hustoty rho_0 až rho_, všechny reprezentující možné stavy konkrétního systému,
spolu s pravděpodobností výběru každého z nich. Kdybychom chtěli, mohli bychom vypočítat vážený průměr těchto matic hustoty
tím, že z nich sestavíme konvexní kombinaci, ale to by nám vlastně neřeklo, jaké jsou jednotlivé stavy nebo jaké jsou
pravděpodobnosti. Místo toho lze udělat, a je to někdy velmi užitečné, je uvažovat matici hustoty
ve tvaru zobrazeném zde na obrazovce. Jde o stav dvou systémů, kde první systém má jeden klasický
stav pro každou z alternativ, a vezmeme vážený průměr m produktových stavů, kde stav prvního systému je
vždy klasický a v podstatě označuje, který z m stavů máme pro druhý
systém. Pokud není zcela jasné, proč bychom chtěli o takových stavech přemýšlet, to nevadí, je to jen příklad
typu korelace, kde první systém je vždy klasický a druhý systém může být v kvantovém
stavu. Třetí kategorií možných korelovaných stavů je množina tzv. separabilních
stavů. Jednoduše řečeno, jsou to konvexní kombinace produktových stavů, a v podstatě reprezentují kvantové
stavy, kde jsou jakékoli korelace mezi systémy klasické korelace. Jeden způsob, jak přemýšlet o
takových stavech, je, že provedeme pravděpodobnostní výběr čísla k a poté nezávisle připravíme dva
systémy v kvantovém stavu, který může záviset na této volbě k. Co je snad nejzajímavější na
stavech tohoto tvaru, je to, že takto vlastně definujeme provázanost v matematickém smyslu. Konkrétně je provázanost
definována jako absence separability. Takže pokud máš matici hustoty a není možné ji vyjádřit ve tvaru
jako tento, pak je podle definice provázaná. Zmínil jsem to v lekci čtyři a zde je to
poněkud podrobněji. Mimochodem, může být velmi obtížné zjistit, zda daná matice hustoty reprezentuje provázaný
stav, a to i s pomocí počítače. Z matematického a výpočetního hlediska je provázanost
ve skutečnosti docela komplikovaná. Na začátku lekce jsem zmínil, že existuje jedna velmi důležitá věc, kterou s maticemi hustoty můžeme dělat,
a to popisovat stavy izolovaných částí systémů, i když jsou korelovány a případně provázány s jinými
systémy. V tomto kontextu se často používá termín redukovaný stav, a jako jednoduchý příklad vypočítáme redukované
stavy pro jednotlivé qubity tvořící ebit. Aby bylo přesno, předpokládejme, že
Alice a Bob sdílejí ebit: Alice drží qubit A, Bob drží qubit B, a dohromady jsou tyto dva qubity ve stavu φ
plus. A otázka, kterou zodpovíme, zní: jaký je stav Alicina qubitu A
izolovaně? Samozřejmě bychom se mohli zeptat na totéž pro Bobův qubit, ale na tuto otázku je snadné odpovědět, jakmile známe odpověď na tuto.
Může být lákavé říci, že stav Alicina qubitu izolovaně popsat nemůžeme, protože je
provázán s Bobovým qubitem, což by nám snad zabraňovalo popis stavu A izolovaně provést nebo o něm vůbec přemýšlet,
ale to je nepravda. Je pravda, že stav A nemůžeme popsat kvantovým stavovým vektorem,
protože, jak uvidíme, není v čistém stavu, ale každý systém má v libovolném okamžiku stav, který lze
popsat maticí hustoty, ať je provázán s jiným systémem nebo ne. Jako myšlenkový experiment, jen abychom si pomohli vidět, jaká je odpověď
na tuto otázku, předpokládejme, že Bob se rozhodne vzít svůj qubit a vydat se ke hvězdám, a nikdo od něj
nikdy více neslyší. Ale představ si, že někde na cestě se rozhodne provést měření ve standardní bázi na svém
qubitu. Víme, jak vypočítat pravděpodobnosti, s jakými dostane oba možné výsledky, a také víme, jaký
bude stav A pro každý možný výsledek, a to vše je shrnuto v této tabulce. Konkrétně s pravděpodobností 1/2
bude A ponechán ve stavu nula a s pravděpodobností 1/2 bude A ponechán ve stavu jedna. A tak, jak bylo diskutováno dříve v
lekci, to nechává A v úplně smíšeném stavu, a to je tedy odpověď
na naši otázku. Možná budeš namítat, že toto závisí na tom,
že se Bob rozhodl měřit svůj qubit, a předpoklad, že to udělá, je součástí příběhu, který nás k této odpovědi přivedl. Ale
pokud je Bob světelné roky daleko v době, kdy měří, nic z toho, co dělá, nemůže mít žádný vliv na jakýkoli
experiment, který by Alice mohla rozhodnout provést na svém qubitu, jinak bychom měli komunikaci rychlejší než světlo.
Alicin qubit je tedy v úplně smíšeném stavu bez ohledu na to, zda Bob
měří. Měl bych v tomto bodě objasnit, že pojem redukovaného stavu a způsob, jakým jsou definovány, ve skutečnosti vůbec nezávisí na relativitě
nebo nemožnosti komunikace rychlejší než světlo. Toto je jen způsob, jak to vysvětlit v doufejme intuitivních termínech.
Ve skutečnosti existuje matematická definice, kterou za chvíli uvidíme v obecnějším kontextu. Je konzistentní s touto odpovědí
a náhodou i s nemožností komunikace rychlejší než světlo, a neexistuje žádná jiná
definice, která by mohla být konzistentní s kvantovými informacemi, jak je známe. Uvažujme nyní redukované stavy
obecněji. Předpokládejme, že máme pár systémů A a B, ne nutně qubity, které jsou dohromady v čistém stavu
reprezentovaném kvantovým stavovým vektorem ψ. Opět se zaměříme na redukovaný stav systému A, a abychom to
udělali, bude užitečné přemýšlet o klasických stavech systému B. Nechme tedy Γ být tato množina
klasických stavů B. Jak jsme probrali dříve, například v druhé lekci série,
existuje jedinečná kolekce vektorů φ_b pro každé b v Γ, pro niž platí vyjádření ψ zobrazené na obrazovce,
a konkrétně existuje jednoduchý vzorec pro tyto vektory. Jednoduše vynásobíme vektor ψ tenzorový součinem
jednotkové matice odpovídající systému A s bra b pro jakékoli b, o které máme zájem.
To, co zde v podstatě děláme, je připravit si výpočet toho, co by se stalo, kdybychom provedli
WEBVTT
měření ve standardní bázi na B, a to bylo pokryto v druhé lekci série.
Předpokládejme tedy, že jsme toto měření ve standardní bázi na B provedli. Každý možný výsledek by pak
nastal s pravděpodobností rovnou euklidovské normě na druhou odpovídajícího vektoru φ_b, a podmíněně na výsledku b normalizujeme vektor
φ_b, abychom určili výsledný stav
A. Stejným uvažováním jako v příkladu s ebitem před chvílí dostaneme vyjádření zobrazené na
obrazovce pro redukovaný stav A jako matici hustoty. A mimochodem, norma na druhou ve jmenovateli pochází z
násobení normalizovaného vektoru jeho konjugovaným transposem, takže dostaneme euklidovskou normu dvakrát
ve jmenovateli. Euklidovské normy na druhou se vyruší a zbyde nám docela jednoduché
vyjádření. A vlastně, pokud dosadíme náš vzorec pro φ_b, který platí pro každé b, dostaneme vzorec pro redukovaný
stav systému A v termínech popisu matice hustoty čistého stavu, se kterým jsme začali, tedy ket ψ bra ψ.
Takže toto je náš vzorec pro redukovaný stav systému A, za předpokladu, že složený systém AB začal v
čistém stavu ψ. Vzorec ale můžeme použít i obecněji. Konkrétně předpokládejme,
že stav AB je dán nějakou maticí hustoty rho, která může mít tvar ket ψ bra ψ pro nějaký kvantový stavový
vektor ψ, ale nemusí. Plyne v podstatě z linearity, že redukovaný stav A je
určen stejným vzorcem jako pro čisté stavy, jenže dosadíme jakoukoli matici hustoty rho,
kterou chceme. Jako zkrácená notace je celkem běžné, že redukovaný stav označujeme tím, co používáme pro
matici hustoty rho v tomto případě, ale s dolním indexem označujícím systém, na který se zaměřujeme. Takže rho s dolním indexem
A znamená redukovaný stav A, když je složený systém ve stavu rho. Někdy se také používají horní indexy
místo dolních, v podstatě jen podle osobní preference, a znamená to totéž.
Zaměřili jsme se na systém A jen pro jednoduchost, ale analogicky také můžeme získat redukovaný stav systému B,
ale vzorec je upraven přirozeným způsobem. Vše je symetrické, v podstatě jen
vyměňujeme role A a B, a konkrétně suma nyní probíhá přes klasické stavy A, tentokrát
místo B, a ve vzorci na obrazovce předpokládáme, že klasická stavová množina A se nazývá
Sigma. To vše se docela přímočaře zobecňuje na tři a více systémů. Například pokud máme tři
systémy A, B a C, které jsou dohromady ve stavu popsaném maticí hustoty rho, pak můžeme získat
redukovaný stav páru A a B dohromady pomocí vzorce zobrazeného zde, jakož i stav třetího systému samotného,
což je druhý vzorec. A lze uvažovat jiné kombinace a zobecnit to na libovolný počet systémů. Sumy vždy probíhají přes
klasické stavové množiny systémů, které jsou ignorovány, a vzor je vždy stejný, přičemž matice hustoty,
se kterou jsme začali, je zaklíněna mezi tenzorový součin jednotkové matice a brasů a ketů odpovídajících standardním bázovým
stavům. Na závěr lekce ještě trochu navíc k definicím, které jsme právě probrali. Operace na maticích hustoty,
která popisuje redukované stavy, má název a nazývá se parciální stopa. Pro dva systémy A a B je
parciální stopa přes B a parciální stopa přes A definovány zde na obrazovce. Jsou to přesně tytéž
vzorce, které jsme viděli před chvílí, a nyní jen přemýšlíme o nich jako o funkcích z rho, a dáváme jim
názvy. Názvy vypadají jako stopa, jenže s dolním indexem, který nám říká, který systém je odstraněn,
jinými slovy, který systém je ten, jehož klasickou stavovou množinu sčítáme a který je zaklíněn mezi bra a
ket. Když bereme parciální stopu rho přes B, například, jak je popsáno prvním vzorcem, někdy říkáme, že
B je vystopován, a podobně pro A. Intuitivně, vystopování systému
jen znamená, že ho zahodíme nebo jednoduše ignorujeme. To je jeden způsob, jak definovat parciální
stopu. Jiný ekvivalentní způsob je říci, že tato zobrazení jsou jedinečná lineární zobrazení, která splňují
vzorce zobrazené zde vpravo. Konkrétně, pokud máme tenzorový součin dvou matic M a N, řekněme,
a provedeme parciální stopu přes první systém, dostaneme stopu první matice M krát
druhou matici. A podmínka je symetrická, když stoupujeme přes druhý systém. Každá matice, u níž bychom vypočítali parciální stopu, nemusí
být tenzorový součin takového druhu, ale každou matici lze vyjádřit jako lineární kombinaci
tenzorových součinů, a parciální stopu lze z těchto podmínek spolu s tím, že jsou to lineární
funkce, určit. A proto se to nazývá parciální stopa. Tato ekvivalentní definice může být
celkem užitečná, protože ji lze často použít místo původního vzorce. Zde je příklad, který
to ilustruje. Předpokládejme, že máme pár qubitů A a B ve stavu, jehož matice hustoty je zobrazena zde na
obrazovce. Toto je náhodou příklad korelovaného stavu, kde A je buď ve stavu nula nebo ve stavu jedna, každý
s pravděpodobností 1/2. Takže A si můžeme myslet jako klasický. Pokud je A ve stavu nula, pak
tak je i B, a pokud je A ve stavu jedna, pak B je ve stavu plus. Pokud chceme znát redukovaný stav A,
vystopujeme B. A pokud použijeme druhý vzorec z ekvivalentní definice spolu s linearitou, pak to
vypočítáme celkem snadno. Konkrétně stopa ket 0 bra 0 je jedna, a totéž platí pro stopu ket plus bra
plus, takže tyto tenzorové faktory zmizí a zbyde nám úplně smíšený stav. Podobně můžeme vypočítat
redukovaný stav B vystopováním A. Tentokrát provádíme stopu na prvním tenzorovém faktoru, takže
používáme první vzorec z ekvivalentní definice, a zbyde nám 1/2 krát ket 0 bra 0 plus 1/2 krát ket
plus bra plus, neboli jinými slovy tatáž matice hustoty, která se objevila několikrát předtím. Dostaneš přesně
stejné výsledky, pokud použiješ vzorce z první definice, ale toto je mnohem jednodušší způsob, jak to udělat. To vše se zobecňuje na tři a více
systémů, ale pro toto video se zde zastavím a nechám to na tobě, abys o tom přemýšlel/a sám/sama. A to je vše k této lekci, která
představila matice hustoty a popsala základy jejich fungování. Diskutovali jsme také o Blochově sféře
a různých typech korelací a pojmu redukovaného stavu systému. Doufám, že se připojíš k
další lekci, která je o kanálech, což jsou lineární zobrazení z matic hustoty do matic hustoty, jež
WEBVTT
popisují operace na systémech. Nashledanou příště.
Sbohem.